la policía turca detuvo a decenas de
personas según la televisión Estatal
fueron acusadas de financiar reclutar y
difundir propaganda para el partido de
los trabajadores de kurdistán El pkk un
grupo considerado como terrorista por el
gobierno Turco el operativo policial fue
realizado en la ciudad más grande del
sureste kurdo de Turquía y en otras
partes del país incluyendo Estambul en
el operativo policial quedaron retenidos
abogados periodistas y políticos y se
produce a menos de tres semanas de las
elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias de Turquía programadas
para el próximo 14 de mayo Los comicios
representan el mayor desafío al que se
han enfrentado el presidente
erdoan y su partido el akp el legislador
timelon diputado kurdo del partido
democrático de los pueblos condenó el
operativo policial y dijo en vísperas de
las elecciones por temor a perder el
poder han vuelto a recurrir a operativos
de detención las redadas añaden presión
al que es el tercer partido más grande
de Turquía y actualmente se enfrenta a
audiencias judiciales por presuntos
vínculos con el terrorismo y podría ser
prohibido un portavoz de humans right
Swatch describió La Ronda de arrestos
como claramente un abuso de poder y una
táctica de intimidación antes de las
elecciones se espera que los comicios
presidenciales de mayo sean una carrera
reñida para erdoan con el control del
parlamento por parte de su partido
también bajo amenaza